hello
my name is matthew memoly i'm the
director of the laboratory of infectious
diseases clinical studies unit
in niad at the national institutes of
health
today i'm going to talk a little bit
about a project that we've done over the
course of the
last year this was a large-scale
zero survey to investigate
the number of undiagnosed infections
that existed
early in the pandemic with the sars cov2
virus
i'm going to talk about the initial
results from that study
that are about to be published and talk
about what they mean
how maybe we could think about those
results and then
use that as a springboard to talk
briefly about why we need to be thinking
about broadly protective
slash universal beta coronavirus
vaccines
so just a quick disclaimer uh some of
the things i'm going to offer are my
opinions as a scientist
uh so when i talk about some of the
interpretations
of the results and some of the things
that i'm taking away from them
i want to be clear those are not the
official position of the u.s government
the nih
dr collins or dr fauci uh these are
again as i said opinions based on my
experience with respiratory viruses
uh as the director of the clinical
studies unit uh
in which that i've been doing studies of
various aspects on respiratory viruses
for the past 16 years also i want to
make clear that i have no financial
interests or connections to any company
or vaccine manufacturer
so the study that i'm going to talk
about here for the majority of the time
is a what we call a trans nih effort it
included
individuals from multiple institutes
within
the national institutes of health my
team the lab of infectious diseases led
this study i was the pi of the study
but we had a lot of assistance from a
lot of other people
these included resources
clinical resources particularly sites
that helped us do the study
through the national center for
advancing translational sciences
we had a lot of laboratory support from
dr sattler
in the section for immunoengineering at
the national institute of biomedical
imaging and bioengineering
and a lot of support in terms of the
production of the antigens that we used
to do tests from nci frederick in the
national cancer institute particularly
dominic esposito
and it really took all four institutes
together
uh to to get this study done and so
we're very proud of the fact that we did
this as a large collaborative effort
so this study was a clinical protocol
that we started
last april uh so shortly after the the
pandemic really began
in the united states in march we started
this study in april and the primary
objective of the study
was to estimate the number of people or
the prevalence of antibodies
in people that were undiagnosed with
covet or sars cov2 infection
so we wanted to really get an idea right
away
how many people have seen this virus
have been infected or been exposed
but didn't know it essentially and how
do those numbers
compare to the numbers of
cases that were actually identified and
so as a primary outcome measured we used
an anti-sars kobe 2
spike and receptor binding domain
elisa assay so we looked for antibodies
against the spike in the rbd those
antibodies included
igg igm and iga subtypes
we've now moved on to a phase two part
of this study which includes a follow-up
which i'll talk briefly about at the end
but what i'm going to talk to you today
about
for the most part is this phase one
portion of the study and the results of
that portion of the study
so how did we do this study well we were
under
unusual circumstances for getting this
study done we wanted to rapidly
recruit individuals get blood from them
and test them
but do this in an environment in which
we were
under very strict social distancing
rules if you remember
at that time in the pandemic in april
was when really everything was locking
down
people were not going to work no one was
going to school everything really was
shutting down and so this wasn't going
to be easy
so we devised a method in which we could
access people at home and this gave us
two benefits one we could stay socially
distanced
but two we could access the entire
country and do this as a nationwide
study and this was really
exciting to us because being able to do
this on that biggest scale
was something no one was doing at the
time
so my group in the lid we led the
recruitment and coordinated the study we
worked with multiple sites
from the national center for advancement
translational sciences
and we had call centers set up in which
we could call individuals who
volunteered
uh and then uh consent them by phone
for the study uh ask them
the necessary questions send them
electronic questionnaires
by email and then send them a home
sampling kit in the mail
and this was something that i discovered
in searching around for a way to do this
there were these kits called the metra
home sampling kit made by a company
called neoterrix
which you see down in the bottom right
which were able to collect
20 microliters of blood per tip from a
simple finger stick
and we were able to get 80 microliters
of blood from individuals who were
willing to give us four of those tips
from one finger stick
they could be mailed back to us safely
in the mail
stored dried diluted and then used for
testing antibodies and it turned out
that this worked
really well so this gave us the ability
to collect blood
from the entire country without ever
having to interact with anybody or
having to have them go and get their
blood drawn they were able to do this
themselves at home
so this really made this study possible
and with the help of the university of
pittsburgh and university alabama
we were able to recruit the individuals
we needed to do this study
in the laboratory dr sattler led the
efforts to standardize
elisa testing for these samples and so
she tested both
fresh blood and dried blood on the tips
using the elisa methods for both the
spike and the rbd
she did a lot of work devising the
optimal antigens to use
the constructs and so on and so forth
and eventually
came up with a very nice sensitive and
specific
elisa for both the spike and the rbd and
we used a method in which
we tested both igg and igm for both the
spike and the rbd
and in order to be determined as a true
positive you had to have
at least one spike and one rbd
antibody positive so either both iggs
both igms or a combination of one igg
and one igm
and this gave us a really nice
specificity and working with our
statisticians
we were able to devise the optimal
cutoffs for these assays
so that we were really getting a nice
specific result
uh and and ideally not calling anyone
who wasn't truly a positive a positive
while at the same time not losing too
many true positives
as false negatives
and i should mention those those methods
were published
uh previously in nature communications
uh
in mid 2020
so what happened with this zero survey
that we did so
we actually were able to identify 462
almost 463 thousand volunteers
so this was through advertising press
release
we had an email set up in which people
responded as well as phone calls
saying they were interested in
participating in the study so we were
just amazed at how great a response we
had and how many people were interested
in participating in this study
now we didn't need that many people that
was way more than we could possibly test
but but this gave us a really nice base
to work with
and so what we did was because we wanted
to access the entire country and get a
very representative sample
we sent all of those individuals a
simple demographic screening question
so questions like what's your race
what's your ethnicity your age your sex
where do you live and so on and so forth
we had 241 000 people respond to that
demographic survey
so now we had basic demographics on over
240 000 people
this allowed us then to use a
custom computer program to
do what's called daily quota sampling so
we had selection criteria based on the
location where people lived
the age the sex the ethnicity those
factors that i was talking about i'm
going to show you those in a minute
and we said you know based on the u.s
census data
how many of these different types of
people do we need from different parts
of the country
to have a representative sample and so
the computer
on a daily basis would access this
database of people
and determine uh which people we needed
to meet our quotas over the correct time
frame that we were doing this so that we
would get a nice representative sample
spread across the entire time frame that
we were doing the study
and so this took any kind of
subjectiveness to the patient selection
out of the question and gets rid of that
bias
it was completely objective and based on
getting that representative sample
and this turned out that it worked
really well uh the computer would give
us a list of people to call
the call centers would call those people
try to recruit them some would come
some would join the some wouldn't and
then the next day we'd get a new list of
people to call
and we did that day after day until we
reached the number of people that we
needed in the study
uh so we invited over 27 000 people into
the study
you can see in this slide it shows you
the different things that happened some
people didn't want to do it some people
didn't respond
but we had over 11 000 people accept the
invitation into the study
we ultimately enrolled 11 283 people
those individuals now were all sent
electronic questionnaires to gather more
information about them
as well as a blood kit
as i showed you a few minutes ago that
micro sampling kit
and as you can see again different
things happen when you do these kinds of
studies
ultimately we had 9089 people return
their kits and samples as well as
surveys
and then when you analyze those data of
course there's always sometimes some
samples that don't work
some samples that aren't in good
condition people didn't fill out the
questionnaires right what have you
ultimately we ended up with 8058 people
which we had a full data set on that we
were able to use for the analysis
and this slide goes through a little bit
more about you know how we did that but
but those are basically the numbers so
ultimately we had 8058 people
spread across the entire united states
and i'm going to show you how that
looked right now
so the first thing we did once we had
all this data was we wanted to
look and determine how representative of
a sample do we have
you know did our selection criteria work
and so
we we went ahead and compared our zero
survey population which you're seeing
over on the right
to the u.s population based on census
data
and what you see is that for our
selection criteria
which are listed in this slide things
like the geography where did someone
live
their age their sex their race their
ethnicity and whether they lived in an
urban or rural area
we did extremely well for example
16.7 percent of the people in our study
were from the northeast
compared to 17.6 percent of people in
the us census
really close same goes for the other
regions of the country as you can see
here
age group i we did really well again 42
between 18 and 45 compared to 46 percent
the u.s census
15 percent between 70 and 95 compared to
14
the u.s census so again very close
numbers so we're really happy with this
the same went for sex uh as well as
urban and rural
and then race and ethnicity now you will
see some small discrepancies for example
we're a little short on
on black participants only 9.2 percent
in our study compared to 12.9 percent
but we were still very close and what we
did do is as we did the analysis
we did look at any of these
discrepancies that were present in the
data
and we weighted the results to make up
for those discrepancies
so you can adjust for the small lack in
black participants or say the small lack
in 18 to 45 year olds by
adjusting the meaning of each individual
in your study
and so we didn't have to do this very
much for the
selection criteria however we did have
to do this a little bit more
for the other criteria the non-selection
criteria that we also weighed our
samples for
so obviously we couldn't we couldn't use
every single possible criteria for
selection we had to decide on what we
were going to use
which you saw in the previous slide but
on this
slide what you're seeing are additional
weighting criteria so this was
additional information that we collected
on the individuals once they were in the
study
that we then compared to the u.s census
and made adjustments for
if necessary and i'll give you some
examples of why so you can see we looked
at how many people had children
that wasn't too far off from the general
population
but when you look at education for
example we had a
far more highly educated group of
individuals in our study than in the
united states
82 percent of our participants either
graduated college or had
more education than college whereas only
28
of the united states you know falls into
that category
so this was obviously a very large
discrepancy and we had to do significant
waiting to adjust for that factor
uh another good example here would be
whether people had received a flu
vaccine in the previous year
you can see that we actually had a much
higher
numb percentage of people who had
received flu vaccine who participated in
this study
compared to the general population so
that was another thing that we had to
you know significantly wait for
but if you as you look at all these
numbers you do see some discrepancies
every single one of these including the
selection criteria and these criteria
were taken into account and waiting was
done uh as needed
as part of the statistical analysis and
in our paper
this is all explained in detail in the
appendix
that will be included with that paper
when it comes out in science
translational medicine hopefully within
the next few weeks
so going further into the results we
know we had a pretty good representative
population uh it was representative of
the age
sex race ethnicity and locations in the
united states
so what did we actually find now
remember what we were trying to do was
we were trying to look for
how many people were seropositive
meaning had antibodies against sars kobe
2
but did not know that they had been
infected or exposed so they had never
gone to a doctor they had never had a
test they had never been diagnosed i
mean maybe they had a test it was
negative but they had never been told
you have sars cov2 by any test or any
doctor
and uh and so when we look at this and
and again remember this is between april
and august of 2020 so right after the
epidemic began
that first sort of five or six months we
were looking at
uh and when we look at that what we find
is that
the northeast and the mid-atlantic had
the highest rate of undiagnosed zero
positivity so he had 7.5 percent in the
northeast
8.6 in the mid-atlantic that those
numbers are a bit smaller
3 percent in south central part of the
united states 1.6 percent in the midwest
4.5 in the mountain and southwest and
1.9
on the west coast now interestingly if
you look at this what you find is that
if you think back to march
april may what you'll find is the
greatest number of cases were in the
northeast in the mid-atlantic
and then as the pandemic progressed you
started to see it moving to the southern
part of the united states then into that
sort of as well as the pacific and the
mountain so
what this is showing you is that initial
snapshot
before the virus really started to
spread
further throughout the country so this
is a very sort of early snapshot
and so these data made a lot of sense to
us based on where the cases were
as it as it to some degree mirrored
where
the most cases of covid were in the
united states at that time
but as you can see there were
significant numbers of undiagnosed cases
in the united states at this time in
fact
when you look at these numbers uh
ultimately what you get
is that there were almost five cases
of sars kobe 2 for every one diagnosed
case
by about mid july so so if you take the
which is about the
sort of mid to slightly mid to later
point of when we
sort of when we sort of hit the peak
recruitment of our study
uh that july midpoint around july 15
we calculated about it's 4.6 almost five
cases
for each individual case that was
identified so at that time
uh you had uh you know a certain number
of cases
but you had much more significant
numbers of undiagnosed cases going on at
the same time that we didn't know about
we'll we'll talk more about that in a
minute digging further into this data
we looked at all these different
criteria that i talked about earlier
and tried to determine were any of these
criteria
more or less related with the chance of
having
uh an undiagnosed infection
so as you can see people in the
northeast and the mid-atlantic were more
likely
although uh not necessarily
statistically significant because the
confidence of interval
crosses uh that midline that midline
that you're seeing on this slide
represents the
uh the sort of average uh which was the
average
uh uh rate of estimate for
uh undiagnosed infection so to the right
means it's more than average and to the
left it's less than average so uh you
could see
exactly what we saw on the map that
certain regions had more than average
certain regions had less than average
when you look at age you see you had
more in the younger age groups the older
age groups you had less
male and female actually female was
slightly higher
uh when you look at races a lot of this
has been discussed i think you see that
really significant numbers in the black
population uh they were much more likely
to have an undiagnosed infection than
the general population uh
as we're the multiple race uh but but
really
you know the black population stands out
the most here uh
hispanic as well a little bit higher not
as much as the black but again a little
bit higher
and you can see urban more likely than
rural i mean rural was way below average
so if you lived in a rural area you were
much less likely
at least at this time between april and
august
to have an undiagnosed infection
now some things i want to point out
about this data that's interesting when
you think about it
so if you look here
one of the reasons why you may have less
undiagnosed infection say in the 70 plus
group than
average is because you are probably
capturing more of the root of the cases
the reason is 70 year olds who got covid
tended to do worse
and seek medical care so they were more
likely to have a test
and actually find out that they had
coveted therefore it makes sense that
you would have
less undiagnosed infections in a 70 year
old than say an 18 to 44 year old
who was more likely to just have maybe
loss of a sense of smell or a little
cough but be fine and so they might not
even have bothered to go to the doctor
or even realize they were sick
so so so in some ways you can explain
these numbers by
you know by that severity of disease
that we saw in the differences in ages
and interestingly if you start thinking
about the races and ethnicities
uh you know because we have such a high
level of undiagnosed infections in the
black population
that may be more relate not necessarily
related to the fact that they had a
higher risk of coping
but actually they were just more likely
to either
not go to the doctor maybe they didn't
have access to health care
and weren't able to go to the doctor or
uh
or they just had less severe disease
and so you had a lot of people who just
never
needed to seek medical care so we in
other words
the true case numbers that we have
actually identified
less than the true cases that are out
there in the black population for
whatever reason uh and so it's likely
the mortality rate is actually much
lower than the cdc estimate
so this is very interesting because when
you look at these kind of data and then
you go back and you look at the case
data and the cdc data
it sort of changes how you need to think
about those things and
i'll talk about that a little bit more
here in a second
so we have lots of other factors and i
know this is hard to read
um there's there's a whole you know list
of different things we asked people
about their lives uh to try to determine
what was related to
having undiagnosed covet infection i
just summarized some points here
uh when we asked people if they had
direct contact with patients so in other
words health care workers ambulance
workers
anybody that would come into contact
with a cobit patient on a regular basis
it actually didn't make a difference
they were right on the average
so healthcare workers fell right on the
average uh made no difference to their
risk of undiagnosed or diagnosed
infection
it just did healthcare coverage again
didn't change anything so whether you
had health care or not
didn't make a difference there was the
same chance of having an undiagnosed
infection
interestingly uh people who had had a
flu vaccine
or pneumovax the pneumonia vaccine
recently
they were statistically associated with
lower seropositivity
now why that is maybe it's behavioral
maybe people who
go out and seek those vaccines were more
likely to you know wash their hands be
more careful
not be around people who are sick i
don't know
but uh it's interesting uh also
people with diabetes were statistically
associated with a lower sero positivity
again maybe behavioral
a lot of people with diabetes maybe
you're more careful about getting sick
or maybe it has to do with sometimes
diabetes can affect your immune system
and you don't have as good an immune
response and maybe we couldn't detect
antibody even after they had been
exposed
because their immune system wasn't
responding as well again i don't know
the true answer
i'm just throwing out you know some
possibilities here and there may be
others
uh some other interesting things that
were actually associated with a higher
prevalence of zero positivity
uh so not surprising anybody with a
known coven 19 exposure so anybody who
said yes
you know one of my family members or
somebody i knew or
i was you know somewhere where i knew i
was exposed
they were much more likely to have
antibodies against sars kobe 2. so not
surprising
uh being unemployed this was interesting
we asked people
if they were working full-time working
from home or they were unemployed and
actually being
unemployed you were more likely to be
zero positive than any other
situations in atypical living situations
so you don't own you don't rent
either you're homeless although we
didn't really have a lot of homeless
people in our study but maybe you
you know live with somebody or you live
in some facility you know different
sort of more atypical living situations
that those individuals are more likely
to be seropositive
anyone with international travel i think
that's not surprising
uh what was a little surprising to me
was people with hiv and kidney disease
were more likely
[Music]
unclear why that is uh you know
generally those types of individuals
obviously would be around hospitals more
frequently because either they take
medications or they need to see doctors
more frequently
so maybe that's why there was some
exposure there uh
but i would have thought maybe they'd be
a little bit more like the diabetes
individuals who would be
trying to be more careful but you know
again i i can't explain all these
results
uh but they're they're very interesting
uh and and i think things that we need
to continue to think about
and do research on to try to better
understand
so the things that i took away from all
these data
well one as i mentioned we estimated
about 4.8 undiagnosed cases per
identified case in the u.s by mid july
of 2020
so that adds about 16.8 million cases to
the 3 million that were diagnosed by
july
15th so now you're at about 20 million
cases by july
the reported case fatality rate at that
time was 4.4
right now the last time i checked a few
weeks ago it was being reported at about
1.8
but in reality based on these numbers
the case fatality rate at least in july
was
probably 0.8 or less in fact i think
it's likely that cfr is even
lower which really makes it similar to a
novel influenza virus i mean a typical
flu pandemic say like the 2009 pandemic
you're talking about
point one percent uh you know uh
0.05 case fatality rate and i think
we're approaching those numbers
uh when we start taking into account the
number of asymptomatic
or undiagnosed infections where people
didn't die and didn't get sick enough to
seek
treatment we're starting to approach a
novel flu virus type number
these data demonstrate how rapidly the
virus spread
and that despite you know what one would
argue are fairly draconian public health
measures
uh 10 of the adult population had been
infected within five months
i mean you take 20 million cases out of
the adult population that's 10 percent
of the
you know 200 million adults in the
united states so
uh you know it makes you question uh you
know were the did the public health
measures do what we said they were gonna
do
i don't know uh you know maybe things
would have been worse if we didn't do it
but you know i think we should think
about that um
you know and it's likely that we've had
at least 60 to 100 million infections in
the united states by now 30 to 50
of the adult population and it's
possibly even more uh
i think these are conservative numbers
that i have here we also have to take
into account that it's possible there
are some
individuals in the united states that
may not be susceptible may not mount an
immune response
so there may be people who either have
been infected and we don't know it
because they don't mount a good immune
response to the spike or the rbd so we
wouldn't be able to detect it
and there may be some people who are
can't even be infected by this virus
for some genetic or other reason so
you know what percent of the population
is actually susceptible now
i don't know the answer to that question
uh the serial positivity in this study
uh was
seen higher in younger individuals as we
mentioned earlier
uh you know the case fatality rate in 18
to 44 year olds
as a few weeks ago was being reported at
0.5
again based on the data here i think
we're looking at less than 0.05
which is a far lower number than the
case fatality rate in influenza in young
healthy people so
should we be spending a lot of money and
effort vaccinating younger people 18 to
44 now is it worth the cost and effort
i think it's a question that should be
considered especially because we don't
know what it means for the future
for those individuals when they're older
and i'll explain that in a minute
so why does this lead me to think we
need a universal beta coronavirus
vaccine
well rna viruses change by nature
there's minimal to no error checking uh
in these viruses and so
the evolution of these viruses as they
progress through a population
uh or even as they stay possibly in an
animal host
you see variants or novel strains that
can emerge and this process is
constantly occurring in nature
and when one of these viruses develops
properties that allows it to start
spreading rapidly through humans no one
can predict
but it clearly happens
we were warned of this really when you
think about it
uh by the sars outbreak and the mers
outbreak both beta coronaviruses in fact
sars is 95
similar to sars kobe 2. now these didn't
spread and cause a worldwide pandemic
for various reasons
but they did cause you know significant
problems and concern
through the areas where they began to
spread and
and so you know we had an opportunity to
look at those two outbreaks and say gee
these beta coronaviruses can clearly
cause a problem maybe we need to be
thinking about what we're going to do if
one of them truly
becomes easily spread throughout the
world
and i think had we spent the time and
effort
to finish the research that began
when the sars and mers outbreaks started
there were vaccines that were being made
there was progress being made but to
some degree when these things settle
down and don't cause a pandemic people
lose interest funders lose interest
uh and work doesn't get finished had we
finished that some
some of that work we likely would have
been in a lot better situation when sars
kobe 2 emerged
than we were and so uh i i personally
feel we didn't heed those warnings and i
hope
uh that we we heed the warning of this
pandemic so that we don't end up
in a similar situation again in the
future all the current vaccines that
we're using right now contain the spike
protein in some form or another
and are administered systemically in
order to induce
a systemic response to the spike protein
now this seems to be working and it's
offering protection
but when we look into the future and so
i'm not talking about six months or a
year from now
i'm talking 10 20 30 40 years from now
these vaccines may offer very limited
protection
if very large variants emerge or a
completely novel beta coronavirus strain
emerges
that tries to cause another pandemic in
the future
it's unlikely that a vaccine with this
specific an antigen in it
is going to offer significant protection
and so you know i wonder if we're
repeating history
uh in the early development of the
influenza vaccines
all the focus went on specific vaccines
against the hemoglobin protein
again a surface protein that everyone
can easily measure antibodies to
and so that's what was done and what
we've seen over time
is that yes that vaccine is effective
uh to some degree but it has a lot of
limitations
you have to keep updating it you have to
keep changing it it's limited in how
well it works in the elderly it's
limited in how well it works in
you know compromise people it also
doesn't offer complete protection it
offers certain protection in certain
circumstances in certain ways
uh and what we're finding in influenza
and this is work that i've been doing
over the past 10 years
is that there are other antigens things
like the neuraminidase things like
uh the internal genes that may offer t
cell immunity
that can offer other aspects of immune
response that can be more broadly
protected
and in some cases even better correlates
of protection and so by focusing on the
aha
and manufacturing those vaccines no one
even bothered to think about those other
antigens for many many years until after
the 2009 pandemic
and now we're finally starting to make
progress in that direction so
i don't want to see us repeat that same
history uh
you know we needed to make something
quick and that was done and that's good
but now we need to start thinking how
can we broaden the protection
how can we make better vaccines
the other thing we need to keep in mind
is that this is a mostly mucosal disease
these viruses infect through the mucosal
membranes of the airways and so
and so in order to block that infection
systemic antibodies in the bloodstream
is is not
not you know not your target you really
need to get
immunity at the mucosal level in the
nose in the throat
in the lungs if you really want to block
disease
for these viruses and so you know
thinking about how we can induce more
mucosal immunity with vaccines
extraordinarily important for both
universal broadly protected stars kobe 2
and influenza vaccines
now this question i've raised about
vaccinating the young
one of the things i'm concerned about
and and this is this is simply
theoretical it could be the complete
opposite is that
if you vaccinate young people who have
very little risk of death or
hospitalization
now with a very specific vaccine and
block them from being exposed and
developing immunity to the current
virus is it possible that by not
allowing them to get the full protection
from a virus like this getting exposed
to it so that you develop more t-cell
immunity and other forms of immunity
against other portions of the virus
could you be setting them up in a
situation where 40 years 50 years from
now
when they're a high risk group for such
a pandemic
you could have another pandemic that
that they don't have any protection
against
that if they had had more exposure to
the virus now
they would have had more protection
against when they're in their 60s
because they would have had some of this
other immune memory
now i don't know the answer to this
question it could be completely the
opposite of what i'm saying
but i think it's something we have to
consider and so if we consider that
if we can make a better vaccine a more
broadly protected vaccine a vaccine that
induces
more types of immunity than just against
that spike protein
that may solve this problem without
having to have them exposed to virus
because you could give them a more
broadly protective immunity that
hopefully would
offer them something when they are in
their 60s and possibly exposed to
another similar
situation so you know i think these are
things that as we
you know rush to vaccinate everyone we
really need to be thinking about
uh and so if we do approach these
broadly vex
broadly protected vaccines uh one thing
i always say is that these broadly
protective vaccines
shouldn't just be broadly protective in
terms of the viruses they cover
obviously we want them to try to prevent
infection with any beta coronavirus
but it should also be broadly protective
and that it protects as many different
types of people as possible
as you're seeing in my slide here right
whether it's race ethnicity
age underlying illnesses medications you
take
we want to be able to protect as many of
those different kinds of people as
possible
and really to do that you have to offer
broad immunity of different types
not everyone responds by developing
systemic antibodies against a single
antigen
some people need t cell immunity some
people need
develop antibodies against different
antigens we've seen this in flu
about 10 of the population does not make
antibody against the hemagglutinin but
they have
very good responses against the
neuraminidase what does that mean for
vaccination for them
it's hard to say but it's clear that
people
people are different their immune
systems are different we need to
consider that
as we move forward with these vaccines
and as we think about our strategy for
the future
because we don't want to end up in this
situation again
so just to finish up we are continuing
this study
that i just described into a phase two
this includes a six and twelve month
follow-up of
all of the people that were enrolled so
that over eight thousand people
they're all uh sending us or being
offered the opportunity
to send us a six month and a 12-month
follow-up sample
as well as answering additional
questions about how they've been doing
whether they've been sick whether
they've gotten covered
uh whether they've had the vaccine this
will
allow us to evaluate the evolution of
the pandemic and the asymptomatic
infections
what happened over time so remember i
showed you that in the northeast
and the uh mid-atlantic we have the
highest numbers
you know does that start to catch up in
the rest of the country does the
mid-atlantic and northeast continue to
increase
beyond we're going to find out as we do
that this will help us solidify some of
the numbers that i talked about some of
these
numbers that i'm saying could impact the
true case fatality rates
we're going to find out how much did
testing affect that so for example early
in the pandemic
we're seeing almost five undiagnosed
cases for every one diagnosed case
well we were doing less testing
initially so maybe as we did more
testing
does that number go down or maybe it
doesn't maybe it went up because there
were more cases we don't know
uh this this uh continuation of the
study will help us find out
uh we will be including testing in the
next phase of the study
that can that can determine whether
someone has developed immunity from the
vaccine
or from a natural infection so because
of the way these vaccines are designed
we are able to look for certain antigens
that aren't included in the vaccines
that will help us determine whether
someone has developed a natural
infection versus
a vaccine immunity and so we'll be
looking at that as we move forward how
many people have vaccine immunity alone
how many people have natural immunity
alone how many people might have vaccine
plus natural immunity either because
they were infected after or before they
got the vaccine
these are all questions we're going to
be able to look at and what does that
mean how high are there levels of
immunity based on these different
factors
also we're asking a lot of questions
about how people respond to the vaccine
did they have adverse reactions you know
what happened to them when they got
it uh this will allow us to correlate
their vaccine responses
as well as their natural immunity if
they get exposed
uh to you know sort of what happened
with the vaccines for example
do people who have adverse reactions do
they have stronger immunity
after they get exposed to a virus or
stronger immunity after exposure to a
vaccine or does it not matter
uh so sort of questions that we can
start to interrogate
and then uh you know i hope this will
help us gain further insight into how to
prepare for the inevitable next pandemic
there will be another pandemic
uh could be flu could be a beta
coronavirus could be something new
uh but everything we learn about these
pandemics
can help us with the next one if we
learn the lessons from them and we tend
to
for some reason sometimes not learn
those lessons and so
we need to really really study this uh
look at how it correlates with previous
flute pandemics and think about what we
can do to change our response in the
future
uh and so uh you know lots of people
worked on this
uh and i have to thank all of them uh
and i'll just finish up
and leave you with a quote from thomas
aquinas
uh you know thinking about uh we need to
really think clearly
uh and think logically because uh the
data is very complicated
uh what goes on in these pandemics
sometimes can be very difficult to
understand
and of course with everything that goes
on uh people dying people getting sick
uh it can sometimes be hard uh to keep
our emotions in check but
if we're going to learn from this we're
going to have to do this and really try
to understand
uh what happened what we've done and how
we can do better in the future
thank you